Okay.
Hey,
what's going on is bill burr
and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I'm checking in on you,
although the way I was just cloth when you should be checking in on me.
What are you thinking?
Hey,
what are he smoking and budgets?
You guys,
your bill?
No,
I'm not.
I was just,
uh,
I just,
I got a little sick.
Okay.
I got a little sick,
but not entirely.
I just got a little sick.
I just wrapped on my general hospital,
my,
my 72 episode arc on General Hospital,
um,
12 hour days,
six days a week.
And uh,
we knocked it out and I actually got to see a sneak peek of the,
obviously it's not journal hospital.
I got to see this sneak peek of this thing that I'm going to be a small part of.
As always,
I always paratroop into things that are really cool.
I'm never the main guy.
All right.
That,
that,
that's not the road for me.
You know,
I'm a bald,
redheaded male.
Okay.
I know the deal.
I'm in the background.
I get it.
All right.
You know,
you don't see me cold complaining like some of these fat chicks out here in
Hawaii and I used almost said Hawaii out here in Hollywood.
Like,
oh,
how come I'm not starting in a,
in a,
in a fucking movie because you look like me with a dress.
That's why.
Okay.
And people invest money and they want to make it back.
So at some point you're going to have to deal with the fact that you know,
you're in the van,
man.
All right.
You're not picking the fucking safe.
The lock on the safe.
Anyways,
we rapped on it.
I had a great time.
I took some chances as an actor,
I learned some things.
MMM.
I,
I learned what I always learned whenever I go on a shoot like that.
Just the sheer amount of fucking work,
how hard everybody works on those things.
And it just kills me.
Whenever these politicians,
none of these politicians run for office.
Who Do they talk about?
Did they talk about people busting their asses?
Like people who fucking write scripts and people got to figure out how to then,
you know,
fucking shoot the thing and all these different looks.
And now when they talk about Joe six pack,
Joe Sixpack fucking putting his pants on one leg at a fucking time.
He's got time to go drink a fucking six peck,
you know,
some fucking dope just driving around in a,
in a,
you know,
I don't know why no fucking ice cream truck.
He's getting more love from the next potential president of the United States.
Did that.
Somebody has got to stand there,
hold the fucking microphone over some ball.
Jackass like me for 12 hours a day.
I Dunno.
I think these politicians are rock.
Maybe if all these fucking Hollywood people would quit shitting on half of them.
Maybe the hardworking people in the movie industry,
we get a little more love.
That's just,
just,
I'm just thinking out loud here,
people.
Um,
anyways,
I had a awesome time and I got to work with some amazing actors and uh,
you know,
yeah,
just great storytellers and all that and I had a great fucking time.
Having said that,
I'm old and I'm exhausted.
Um,
all right.
And I got to jump on a red eye tonight to go out,
fly direct to fucking Atlantic city.
Um,
cause I'm doing a Gig at the Borgata tomorrow night.
Okay.
All right.
I'm taking off my acting hat and I'm putting on my standup shirt.
Um,
anyway,
speaking of shirts,
did anybody see that stupid sweater Gucci made?
I'm getting all my news from Twitter by the way.
I've just given into the fact that I'm not going to be an informed person.
All right.
You're listening to the wrong bill.
Okay?
You want to listen to Bill Maher if you want to,
if you want to listen to somebody who knows what the fuck is going on,
okay?
You want to listen to that bill?
All right?
You want to listen to some shithead who reads hashtags and whatnot.
You're listening to the right podcast.
All right.
Gucci sweater,
one of these fucking idiots,
right?
Goes out and he designs his fuck.
He or she.
All right.
Okay.
It was either some dumb guy or a strong brave woman.
Is that my,
is that how he's supposed to say it politically?
Um,
designed a turtle neck that was black that you feel whatever stupid fucking
reason you pulled up like right up underneath your nose and then your,
your mouth came through it.
And then there was these big red lips around it.
Yeah.
So if you've seen the picture,
just Google a picture of it.
All right.
African American people,
you know,
not all of them.
I don't even know how many,
I don't,
I didn't take a fucking sense.
It start going,
Jesus Christ.
Can we start with the fucking black face?
Okay.
This is offensive.
You know,
they said the sweater look like,
yeah,
it was black face and they immediately made it about themselves rather than the
real issue.
Yeah.
Which was that it was an unbelievably ridiculous and ugly fucking turtleneck
sweater.
Okay.
That's all it was.
It was an ugly turn neck sweater or you know,
and I don't,
I don't want to get involved in a racial debate here,
but as a privileged white male,
I want you to know that I was triggered by the fact that all those black people
ignored the fact that there was also half a white face behind that turtleneck.
Okay.
And how do you think I felt to not feel represented?
And that sweater scandal?
Yeah.
Um,
is it a fucking amazing,
that shit that just get light somehow gets traction on social media?
You know,
what about the fucking eight year old,
you know,
who usually goes to bed at three in the morning after?
So when those fucking things together in some sweatshop now he had to stick
around for an extra half hour to,
so the extra fucking thread to make sure it went up and over your mouth.
Right.
And then what happens to everybody in the first world country makes it all about
themselves and everybody forgets about that little fucking kid there.
Right?
Little fucking Joe
six pack.
Right?
Um,
I dunno,
my wife is really into fashion.
I so much of it is just ugly Shit,
you know?
And then they just have some beautiful woman walked down the,
the,
the runway,
like looking confident,
you know.
But that one,
I swear to God,
that was like something out of the muppets,
wasn't it?
I was like the dumb Donald fucking no dump.
Donald had a hat pulled down over his fucking,
I used to know all the fucking Cosby kids who was weird.
Harold,
one of them had a sweater yanked up over its face.
Right over it's wall.
It's a cartoon.
Right?
Hold on a second.
Fat Albert kids.
All right.
Who are they?
Let's see.
What did you have?
What did you have images?
Okay.
Um,
there was one,
was it weird Harold?
No,
didn't one of them.
I guess they didn't.
There was Russell,
Rudy blocky bill.
Dumb Donald.
Weird Harold.
When was the last one?
Mush mouth.
One of those fucking cartoons at somebody with a thing yanked up over its face.
I had,
I don't fucking remember.
Um,
anyway,
so that was a big scandal.
Everybody.
That was a big fucking scandal,
you know?
But thank God people spoke out and those sweaters will not be mass produced.
So whatever ones that they have will now be thrown into the ocean and we'll let
the porpoises and dolphins deal with it.
You know?
I mean it could have kept a lot of half the lower half of a lot of people's
faces warp,
you know,
they easily could have died.
It,
you know,
made it a different color.
I then,
and then what?
Then you get Asians and
native Americans start fucking complaining.
It's just a bad idea though.
I think that's what we learned this week.
You know,
you can't get mad at somebody for trying.
I mean it was a turtle neck sweater.
What the fuck can you do with it?
Can you lower it a little bit?
It's already been done.
Mock turtleneck sweater.
What do we do?
Well,
let's fucking,
let's keep it going.
What do you think?
Underneath the mouth?
No,
right up and over it.
That looks weird.
I'll put some fucking lips on it.
You know,
if you sit sitting there going like bill,
who the fuck talks about half a turtle neck fucking black face sweater for fuck
at eight minutes.
Well you know what,
it's not football season anymore.
Football season is over.
Um,
then your New England patriots.
Yeah,
New England patriots are the fucking champion.
Your Boston Red Sox or the world series champion and it's fucking unbelievable.
You know Bruins,
a play in our right.
I don't know what's going on with the Celtics.
Somebody asked me today on set,
they go,
hey,
is Kyrie Irving going to go to the Lakers?
This kind of a room.
I heard a rumor.
I have no idea.
All I know is I don't think that they've been playing as well as everybody
thought they were going to play.
So I have no idea.
But I'm going to try to check in on that.
All I have to do now,
now that I'm on the other side of that acting Gig,
all right.
Yeah.
All I gotta do now,
you know,
I keep doing the F is for family stuff and at night I'm just going to be running
my hour because I am taping my hour special.
I kind of kept it under wraps as to where I was taping it,
where I was recording it and I feel like now's the time,
you know,
cause it,
it's a very weird time in comedy.
You hear that a lot now is not the time for those jokes.
I'm a white woman who's not even funny and I'm telling you that now is not the
time for that.
Have you noticed that most people who were saying what you should and shouldn't
be saying comedically are about as funny as your average feature act?
They're like Middle Act,
funny telling like fucking really funny people.
What they should be saying.
Um,
Oh yes.
Yes.
You by all means who with your best joke.
You just make me raise my eyebrows a little bit like hmm.
Yeah,
that was a funny,
wasn't it?
By all means.
Tell the world what is funny.
Um,
I am going to be recording my next hour special and um,
Royal Albert Hall in London.
That's right.
I'm a trader.
I'm going back to the motherland,
eh?
Well,
yeah.
What the fuck?
I mean,
I'm on my sixth one.
I've got to try something different.
I'm going to go over there,
be funny.
Half of my shit.
People will be like,
I don't understand that.
And maybe I'll bomb for part of it.
We'll see if it's funny.
Anyways,
I'll be doing it at Royal Albert Hall on a Monday and Tuesday.
March.
Uh,
what the fuck is that?
Third and fourth.
Fourth and fifth.
Fifth and sixth.
Okay.
So I'm going to be doing a run at dates out here.
Um,
why I do the board?
Ghada the fuck month is this.
Oh,
that's October.
Why is this an October?
There's the last time I actually put anything in my calendar.
October 29th I put Jimmy Kimmel.
Okay.
How the fuck do I get out of this?
Click on this today.
Click on today.
All right,
here we go.
I'm sorry.
March.
Yeah,
March 4th and fifth.
All right.
So next week on the 15th,
16th and 17th,
I'll be in Santa Barbara,
I'll be in Pasadena and I'll be,
uh,
in,
Riverside,
California.
And then I go to New York City on the 19th.
And I do the Patrice O'Neal benefit.
And then,
um,
I'm in York for a little bit,
doing some spots out there and then I embark on a little run of dates through
unit,
a great United Kingdom,
Great Britain,
whatever the fuck you call it.
And then I end up at,
MMM,
I ended up a Royal Albert Hall and they have it.
And then when I get on the other side of that Shit when I Sang,
thank you.
Good night on March 5th.
Then all I have to do is worry about wrapping up the writing on season four of f
is for family and I don't have shit until the summertime and I'm just going to
be fucking hanging in Cali doing,
you know,
getting ready to do my new hour work of mine.
That's,
that's the game plan.
All right.
Because,
uh,
I love my daughter and I,
I don't like leaving the way I used to,
you know,
do you know,
she,
she tried to get out of her bed.
I saw two months ago she was swinging her leg up and over the,
the,
the crib and my gut said you better put some pillows down around the floor in
case she goes up and over.
And I just,
you know,
I didn't listen to my gut like a fucking idiot.
So it was coming home from the,
at that amazing shoot that I was on that I can't wait to fucking tell you guys
about,
but I'm just not allowed to,
was so awesome.
Um,
but uh,
I came home last night and you know,
after I got off set,
I never bring my phone down to the set or a watch,
you know,
cause I don't want to know what time it is because then it just makes it drag.
So I just focus on whatever the fuck it is I need to do and then I come walking
out at like one in the morning,
however it works.
Anyway,
some fucking coming back.
You know,
I come outside and I get the,
uh,
oh,
the pizza's here,
I get this text message.
Okay.
And,
uh,
it says we're at the emergency room,
blah,
all this fucking shit.
She fell out of the bed.
Okay.
And I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm wiped out and I have to go to the emergency room and my fucking tires has a
slow leak on the left side.
So I'm like,
great.
It never rent.
So I'm on my way there.
And it's so funny,
like how my wife is wired and how I'm wired.
Like my wife is wired like a normal caring human being.
Okay.
And I'm like a fucking lunatic.
I was raised the way I was raised just in a different time.
So
I call her up,
she goes,
I go,
is she talking?
Is she find,
yeah,
she's fine.
She's joking around,
she's laughing.
She actually didn't even cry until I came in the room and cried.
MMM.
And she sent me a picture,
you know,
and I'm driving and I'm looking at it,
like I shouldn't be.
And I was just like,
yeah,
she's fine.
Okay,
She's got a bump on her head.
She's,
she's going to be fine and blah,
blah,
blah.
And we both had the exact opposite.
She's like,
I'm not bringing her home until a doctor looks at her.
I'll never forgive myself.
And I'm like,
she's fine.
She's fine.
So we walk up to the window to see where we are.
It's like fucking one in the morning or midnight I think.
And there's all these fucking people there with their kids and they're all
screaming and crying.
Okay.
They say we're 16th in line.
It's just like they're not going to get to us to like fucking three in the
morning,
you know,
she's fine.
I literally,
I remember being a kid swinging on these ropes.
My other brother was on another rope and we went right by each other and then
slammed into the backs of our heads,
like slammed into each other.
Like I saw stars.
It all went white and I landed face down on the ground.
Yeah.
All right.
I was out,
like I was conscious when I was on the rope and when we hit,
I was unconscious than I hit the ground.
And you know what my dumb ass did an hour and a half later got right back on
that fucking thing.
And my other brother did too.
And I remember the looks on our faces when we passed each other going,
are we really going to do this again?
And Bam,
back of our heads again,
saw lights knocked out,
hit the ground,
you know.
Okay.
And I was fine,
so fuck it.
So I convinced her that she was all right and she was all right.
But like I've kind of realized in that like I need to like kind of gauge that.
Okay.
Because you know,
I came from a house where like I had a ruptured appendix at one point and my
parents were like,
you're fine,
you're fine.
It finally one of the hospital,
they slice me open and I don't like,
my whole belly was just fucking pus.
You're like,
Jesus Christ.
Um,
yeah.
So whatever you can take that,
rub some dirt on it too far.
And then he can go the other way where every time somebody has to fucking
sniffles you take beyond to the God damn hospital.
You know what I mean?
But I think my wife was right to take her down there,
but she was okay.
And uh,
she woke up today and then not on her head was a lot smaller and uh,
you know,
every kid has to have their black I picture,
you know what I mean?
Um,
something that you did.
So,
uh,
it was cool and I was so proud of her that she didn't cry and she was,
she's a little toughie,
you know,
she's a little bad ass.
So anyways,
you know,
she's talking up a storm and I got my little book and I try to keep up on all
the things that she says,
you know,
um,
it's funny now is uh,
they have a park nearby and like once a year they just,
little carnival thing comes by and they have like little pony rides and stuff.
So I took her over there and you know,
it was going on like all the little kiddie rides with her.
It was awesome.
And um,
and then she saw the horses,
she's like horse horse,
you know,
she knows how to make the noise and shit.
And um,
okay,
they had the little pony rides or do you want to ride the horse?
She goes,
yeah,
right up,
right horse ride horse.
She was all about it.
Right.
And then paid the ticket.
I'm going in.
I was like,
wow,
man,
she's so brave.
You know,
Right.
And uh,
and she was all about it and right as I went to put her down on it because it
can put you down and then they'd like puts this little safety harness and then
you was the parent walk along with it.
Right.
I want to set her down in the second I started setting down.
She's going,
no,
no horse,
no horse.
So I immediately got her out of there cause I didn't want to have her to have
issues with horses.
Speaking of horses,
one of the actors that I worked with that,
um,
you know,
all of this shit I'm not allowed to say knows a thing or two about horses.
And I somehow asked him,
what is that a road rode hard and put up wet.
What does that expression mean?
Or uh,
you know,
there's a couple of different ways to say it,
but that's basically,
it rode hard and put up wet.
He goes,
that's actually talking about horses and it's kind of a human cell.
Somebody like Jesus Christ,
that guy looks rode hard and put up wet.
Um,
and it basically was,
I guess if you ride a horse hard enough that it's,
it's breathing hard and it's sweating.
Yeah.
And you just were to then just walk it into a barn.
Okay.
I guess they get like these stomach cramps or something.
They call it colic or something and they literally laid down in the ground and
they flip around or I don't know what happens.
Something gets twisted up and they just fucking die.
So what you have to do is after he wrote them hard is you have to walk a horse
around until it's slows,
slowly,
cools back down again.
So it doesn't get those cramps.
And if you put it into early and it lays down,
you got to fucking get that thing back up or it's going to die or whatever,
you know,
fucking horse,
just man,
they're really temperamental.
So I had no idea about that shit.
So,
you know,
these are the things that you learn about while you're sitting there.
You know,
I learned all of this Shit I learned about,
you know,
there was an old school guy,
they're telling me about different actors and how much of the,
how much land they owed out owned out here.
You know,
like this,
this actor went out and he bought from this street to this street.
Okay.
Which would,
yeah,
I mean if somebody wants to buy that same parcel land today out here in La,
like I don't even have to be $1 billion or something.
And that person bought it for like five grand.
And then for the rest of their acting career,
they just sort of slowly sold it off and made all this money.
It's,
it's fucking like,
La is one of the most amazing
historic cities.
If you can somehow find out what the fuck happened.
Cause God knows it's not in any books because they don't give a shit out here.
They just fucking pave shit over.
Um,
it's one of the shady ass God damn place.
Awesome.
I fucking love it.
But it is so fucking shady with,
you know,
we used to have street cars and trolleys and all of this fucking shit.
And then one day,
you know,
the,
allegedly this group of people got together,
you know,
that was allegedly the automakers and,
and,
and the Goodyear tire people got together and they bought up the trains and the
trolleys and they just ripped up all the fucking tracks and turned it into this
fucking mess that it is now.
Now I got a Elon must dig in the fucking,
you know,
we,
these already dug this tunnel underneath la and the people that live in Beverly
hills are so fucking rich.
They stopped elong Musk
who's powerful enough to just start drilling underneath the fucking city.
And
yeah,
they're powerful enough to be at.
We do not want those commoners.
Yeah.
Taking public transportation under cause they know what's going to happen is
eventually there is going to be a subway stop in Beverly hills and they're like,
oh no.
Oh No,
no,
no.
We have not worked this fucking hard in our lives to keep these fucking,
to kick,
to get away from these fucking people,
to have them then just get on some magic carpet ride underneath the fucking
surface of the earth.
Tesla style zero to 60 in one point something seconds.
Fuck you.
You're not doing it right.
So they stopped it fucking,
I mean,
you can't do shit and Beverly Hills,
they're like,
fuck you.
We're there.
They're like their own city.
They do whatever the fuck they want to do.
They fucking do it.
Um,
okay.
You know where I live.
It's just like,
hey,
we like that.
Fuck you bulldozers come in.
Um,
anyways,
I got a bunch of ad reads I got to do here.
So let's see.
Let's see if I can fucking knock these out here.
Oh,
in don't cheat.
Talk about how every man looks better and feels more confident when he puts on a
suit.
Well,
yeah,
if you're yeah,
everybody does cause you're dressing up,
you know,
and if you have fat,
the sport coat really hides a lot of pounds to a certain point,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
If you look fatness suit did you just got to get on the God damn treadmill and
this is just tough love.
Okay.
Lay off the Sherry's berries.
Start crushing the water's eating some salads.
You know what the fuck to do?
It's going to melt right off.
Yeah,
that's it.
You know,
cause I got to tell you what global warming,
I mean,
these fucking polar bears are going to start migrating south and you know,
they're used to eating fat seal.
So who the fuck you think they're going after first?
Alright.
And Yeah,
you're big thighs rubbing together as you're running in your fucking slacks.
Indochino is the world's most exciting made to measure men's wear company.
Uh,
they make suits and shirts to your exact measurements for an unparalleled fit
and comfort.
Here's how it works.
Visit a stylist at your show at our showroom and had them take your measurements
personally or measure at home yourself.
Shop online@indochino.com choose your fabric inside and out.
Choose your design customization.
Submit your measurements with your choices.
Relaxed while you're suit gets professionally tailored and mailed to you in a
couple of weeks.
This week,
my listeners can get any premium.
You know what they don't make anymore.
You know those really shiny fucking suits,
those good fellas suits.
It's like you're wearing a suit.
That's all you need to do.
What the fucks with the shine on it.
Uh,
this week,
my lives,
I think it was fucking laminated this week.
My listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for $359.
That's indochino.com when entering burb at checkout,
that's 50% off regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus shipping is
free.
That's indochino.com promo code burr for any premium suit.
Just 359 bucks and free shipping,
a incredible deal for a premium made to measure suit.
Once you go custom,
you never go back.
Um,
alright.
Robin Hood.
Robin Hood is an investment app that lets you buy and sell stocks,
ETFs,
options,
and Cryptos all commission free.
They strive to make financial services work for everyone,
not just the wealthy,
not intimidating non-intimidating way for stock market newcomers to invest for
the first time with true confidence,
simple and intuitive.
Clear design with data presented in an easy to digest way.
Other brokerages charged up to $10 for every trade.
But Robin Hood doesn't charge commission fees,
trade stocks and keep all of your profit.
Oh,
sorry.
Does not charge commission fees,
trade stocks and keep all of your profits easy to understand.
Chats and market data.
Place a trade in just four taps on your smartphone.
Robin Hood Web Platform also lets you view stock collections 100 most populars
and entertainment,
social media,
female CEO's,
curated categories like female CEOs.
If you're into that reverse sexist shit,
uh,
an analyst's ratings of buy slash hold slash sell for every stock.
I tell you guys better get on this pro guy thing.
All right?
If they're going to keep going in this fucking direction,
Jesus Christ before it's overcorrected to the point we can't get,
now all of a sudden we've got to start marching in the street.
You know,
we won't be doing that,
dude.
It's not worth it.
Just let them have everything.
Maybe then they'll stop yelling at us.
Learn how to invest as you build your portfolio.
Discover new stocks.
Track favorite companies with personalities,
newsfeed.
A Robin Hood is giving listeners a free stock like apple,
Ford or sprint to help build your portfolio.
signup@billbirddotrobinhood.com.
That's capital B I L L B U R R A.
Dot Robin hood.com.
That doesn't make sense.
Oh yeah,
it is bill bird dot Robin hood.com.
Okay,
cool.
Um,
you know,
I was thinking the other,
by the way,
I didn't gloat about the Patriots winning the Superbowl because I still can't
believe they fucking did it,
but it does make me feel good.
You know,
after all the shit giant fans gave me that the new England patriots now have
more fucking Tom Brady has more fucking rings then the giants and jets combined
and the buffalo bills.
There are three NFL teams in the state of New York and Tom Brady alone has one
more super bowls than those three teams in their entire fucking existence.
So I'll take those two losses.
Oh,
Boohoo we only went six and three.
Sorry,
just given,
um,
fellow patriots fans some fucking Ammo.
Um,
alright,
1-800-FLOWERS by now most of us had started racking our brains about what
Valentine's Valentine's gift is truly going to make her day special.
I,
it's just blows my mind that there's nothing in here about guys and all the,
all these fucking women do is bitch.
How come I can't announce on Monday night football?
I Dunno.
Cause you have your own fucking holiday.
Isn't that enough for you?
Uh,
with one editor to flowers.com it's really not that complicated.
Roses from 1-800-FLOWERS are a no brainer right now.
When you order early 1-800-FLOWERS has amazing deals on vibrant and Romantic
Valentine's roses,
bouquets and arrangements and more.
Starting at just 30 bucks,
29,
nine isn't that there are so many unbelievable deals.
Hurry to one,
800 flowers.
Uh,
now roses from one,
800 flowers are handpicked,
are picked at their peak,
sorry,
and shipped overnight to ensure freshness and,
and her amazement to ensure freshness and her amazement.
That's a weird sentence.
Gorgeous valentines bouquets and arrangements starting at 29,
nine and nine is an amazing deal,
but it won't last.
Long bouquet prices will be going up soon.
So take advantage today.
Pick your delivery date and let 1-800-FLOWERS handle the rest.
When it comes to Valentines,
um,
you don't settle for anything less than rose authority.
One 800 flowers.com to order Valentine's Day bouquets,
arrangements and more.
Starting at 29 and a nine,
go to one 800 flowers.com.
Click on the radio icon and enter Berbee.
You are our order and save@oneeighthundredflowers.com code [inaudible] how much
they cost?
20.
[inaudible].
Um,
all right,
let's look up steak in a blow job day.
I always heard that that fucking exists.
Is that an actual day steak and a blow job?
God knows a progressive mayor will take a veggie sandwich at a fucking hand job.
Um,
let's see here.
Steak and a blow job.
Alright.
Steak in a blow job day.
Sticking a blow job day is a satirical holiday creating the United States.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's a male response to Valentine's Day and celebrate it.
A month later on March 14th on the day,
women are proport purported to supposedly to cook a fillet steak.
Okay.
Wow.
Yeah.
Good luck getting any woman under the age of fucking 50 to do that.
The women on a cook anymore.
I mean,
I think they do it for themselves and perform fellatio on a man in response to
postcards,
chocolate and flowers by men on Valentine's Day.
The observance has no official status of course,
being a popular Internet meme rather than an actual holiday.
But various souvenirs and video clips have been produced about it.
It was conceived in 2002 by Dj Tom Birdsy on Wfm next radio that's in Boston.
It's been suggested that steak and a blow job day is a backlash against the
feminist movement.
Uh,
it has nothing to do with the feminist movement has to do with the firm.
Why the fuck are we sell?
Why do I only have to buy shit to celebrate that we're together.
Okay.
Anyways.
Oh,
oh.
Who's coming in?
My little toughie.
Hey.
Hey Nia.
Just to let you in.
Do you know when the official stake in a Bj Day is?
When is that?
Uh,
March 14th.
All right.
How well did it in my calendar?
Beautiful.
Just like that.
See that I didn't have to make say anything about feminism.
Did I?
Hi.
Gorgeous.
Oh,
look at you.
You look like it's week two of the playoffs.
Sherry's berries near.
Talk about your plans for Valentine's Day this year.
What would you do if you weren't procrastinating?
I'm not procrastinating.
I already have a reservation that my wife made.
We're going to go out and we're going to have some neat share.
A Personal Valentine's Day story.
All right?
I always tell this story.
One time I was dating this woman and uh,
I didn't know what to get her.
It was like my first girlfriend and I went to the mall and they had these polo
shirts that were on sale,
so I bought three of them for like golf shirts.
That's what I bought a female and she opened them up.
She was all excited and she opened them up and she just went like,
what?
What is this?
Who would buy these?
And she got so mad at me,
she started yelling at me and I was so embarrassed that I literally sat down in
the bed like a scolded child and let her yell at me for like three minutes
before I finally got enough self esteem to tell her to go a,
to go to hell.
And then she tried to back pedal that she actually appreciated the fact that I
went in and I got her gift.
Like it's just like,
sweetheart,
you're not buying me anything.
I know this gift stinks,
but it's the thought that counts.
Right?
Isn't that what it is?
No,
it's the thought.
The shyness and how much you spent,
was it at least three different colors?
Yeah.
Three different color polo shirts.
They were ugly.
She was right.
Uh,
what do you do to look good on Valentine's Day?
Well,
I get a spray Tan for one.
I put on some me undies,
the Greg Logan from the Greg Louganis line.
Um,
I get a spray on like stubble on top of my head,
put on a cumber bun and then I'm out the door.
Never,
never go wrong with signature dip Valentine's strawberries dipped in milk,
dark or white chocolate.
Goodness for any discernible palate.
Uh,
that's very progressive.
Near notice the white chocolate was last.
Okay.
Although milk,
light skin,
there's still,
you know,
still a little prejudice.
It's light skinned to did it.
No,
it's not.
What do you mean it's not light skin?
The color of it that's hockey would be considered light skin.
You're going to try to raise as come here.
Let me,
can I ask you a question yet?
Were you offended by that Gucci?
A half a blackface sweater.
Aye.
Yeah.
The whole thing was just very strange to me.
Didn't you think it was a tribute to half moon cookies?
I did not think that at all.
No,
I didn't think that you can.
It was black,
half of face,
half half black face,
black half phase.
But I felt triggered as a white man that they didn't recognize the half a white
face that was there.
Did you?
Yes.
I'm sure they will.
Anyways,
dipped in milk,
dark or white chocolate.
Goodness for any discerning palate.
She'll fall in love with every bite.
Top with decking it toppings,
chocolate chips,
heart and glitter.
Sparkles.
Perfect companion to a candle lit dinner,
a bouquet of flowers or a night out on the town.
Arrive with 100% Sherry's.
Can you say Sherry's berries?
Sherry's berries?
Yeah.
Guarantee ships anywhere nationally.
Gives sweet somethings to your long distance.
Love Valentine's Day is right around the corner.
I got you a little Valentine's Day card.
You're my buddy.
I got a bike too.
Now I've got two little girlfriends here.
Go to [inaudible] dot com click on the microphone and enter my code.
B,
U,
R R at checkout.
That's B,
e r r,
I,
e s d o t c o m berries.com.
Click on the microphone and enter the code burr order today.
Oh my God.
It's still have one more read here.
Lastly,
but not leastly.
Oh,
zip
recruiter.
She almost did it.
You saying recruiter,
Zip
grabbing them.
She said Zip.
She didn't say sip.
Now say recruiter.
Hey
ZipRecruiter's sends you sense your job to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards,
but they don't stop there with their Paul for all matching technology.
Old Zip,
say recruiter
all day.
Oh,
zip say recruiter,
recruiter.
Um,
I'll make her say zip with their powerful machine to matching technologies.
Ziprecruiter scans thousands of resumes to find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job.
As applications come in,
ZipRecruiter analyzes each one and spotlights the top candidates.
So you never miss a great match zip.
Yeah,
it
is so effective that 80% of employees who post on say,
zip recruiter,
um,
get quality candidates through this site the first day.
And right now my listeners can try say zip,
Zip,
zip.
Say it.
Say Zip recruiter.
Right now my listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free at this exclusive web
address,
ziprecruiter.com/burr that's ziprecruiter.com/slash bar one more time.
Say Zip
recruiter,
Zip,
The smartest way to hire.
All right.
Listen to this lovely music here.
Um,
and then we have another half hour bonus material from a Thursday afternoon just
before Friday,
Monday morning podcasts to go by.
Thank you to everybody that I worked with over the last two weeks on this acting
gig.
Thank you.
Everybody gave me the opportunity.
I had an unbelievably awesome time.
Um,
and I can't wait for you guys to see and I can't wait for you to tell you what
it is.
And when I do,
you're going to be like,
oh my God.
No you didn't.
I'm like,
yes.
Hi.
I'll talk to you later.
Wow.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 7th,
2011 seven days into February.
I'm actually doing this Sunday night,
which is why all you mother fuckers in Europe actually got this fucking podcast
on Monday morning and everyone across the states got it Monday morning.
All right.
And even if you're on a fucking oil tanker in the middle of the Goddamn Atlantic
Ocean,
all right?
If you didn't have to go off and swab the deck or whatever the fuck it is you
people do out there,
you got it on a Monday morning.
So I don't wanna hear any God damn bitch in this week.
Where are you?
Could you made your body pod casts?
It's my podcast.
You're probably asking yourself,
why do I work in a cubicle?
But beyond that,
you probably ask yourself,
why did bill actually do one on a Sunday evening?
So it was actually there for his listeners on a Monday.
Maybe if he did that more often,
he wouldn't beat ranked number 52 on iTunes.
According to one of my listeners,
he let me know that he loved my podcast and he thought that I should be ranked
much higher than number 52 well,
thanks a lot.
Thanks for letting me know how far down the fucking ranks I am
when you're doing rankings.
Who counts beyond the top 20 honestly,
coming in at number 73 Mabel Millan field with her,
uh,
how to make a pot roast podcast every week she talks about how to make a
podcast.
You'd figured that that would get boring way to go,
whatever made up name,
I said five seconds ago.
So I'm doing it because I'm fucking busy today on Monday.
Uh,
believe it or not,
I actually,
I booked some acting work.
You know,
it's a great thing,
you know,
when you,
uh,
you know,
being in this business,
you can watch shows on TV and be fans of them.
And actually,
Lo and behold,
one day I should be on the fucking show.
And,
uh,
since its inception,
this very few shows that I watch every episode of,
and I just have to tell you from day one,
I have just loved that show glee.
I mean,
it is just phenomenal.
You know,
the singing,
the dancing,
the way they stole the Nelly Olson character from little house in the prairie
matters,
some old country with the fucking rape whistle,
right?
It's a great God damn show.
And evidently they've been listening to my podcast and they can,
you know,
they hear that I can belt out a tune,
I could carry a tune and um,
you know,
I'm going to go on this thing a little bit Tony Bennet and uh,
I can't,
I'm,
you know,
I'm legally obligated to not say what the entire episode is about.
So,
uh,
yeah.
So I'm actually,
I'm taping an episode of Glee this week
and if you believe that I um,
I got a fucking,
I got a,
I got a wind screen to sell Ya.
Ya know,
I am working this week as an actor.
I'm not fucking telling you on which show.
Okay.
You figure it out.
All right.
There's only 600 channels,
you know,
how far into my life do I have to let you.
But I am working as an actor.
I'm fucking psyched because my pilot for comedy central that I was doing a with
another,
one of the funniest fucking Comedians I know did not get picked up.
That's how my year began.
Began with the little bit of hope for about two weeks.
And then the industry grab one of my ankles and then someone else,
he ended,
she grabbed the other ankle and then they drove a fucking TD emblem right into
my ball bag and it said,
hey,
you got bell,
have a great fucking 2011.
You know,
and that was down in the dumps for a couple,
two,
three days.
But you know,
just like one of those old,
uh,
one of those old fucking crooners songs,
jazz,
what makes that little hack?
They key can stomp dance something in South Day and everyone knows that your
fucked,
but you don't got the balls to kill yourself.
So you keep a dash shinning.
See,
can you believe I'm not,
I'm fucking glee.
Um,
I can't to go fuck yourself.
You figure it out when I'm on.
All right.
Um,
so anyways,
so this is the podcast.
So I was going to do it this afternoon and,
uh,
I dunno,
a day got away from me and then I was like,
wow,
the super bowls today.
So I gotta make sure I do it after the super bowl because I always talk about
sports.
And,
uh,
if you're someone who's a hates,
when I talk about sports,
you really get to hate this podcast.
All right?
Cause I got to talk about a little bit.
There was the fucking super bowl and you know,
you showed up,
you sport hate and can't,
didn't you?
And you sat there and you ate the fucking food,
And you've ran your mouth during the fucking game and then you shut up during
the commercials,
right?
And then you gab with all the chicks afterwards.
I thought that that was the good one.
Can you,
do you believe they pay nine zillion dollars a second?
Right?
So shut your face.
People will say they hate fucking sports.
Still show up to Superbowl parties.
All right?
If you do that,
you're,
you're a punk.
All right?
When I say I hate sex in the city,
I don't show up for the season finale.
You know,
I don't go to the movies.
They are,
that's what I should do when they make another one of those horrific movies,
right?
Do you know,
I heard most of the budgets of those movies is,
uh,
is actually a dying,
the pubes of the women who play those girls.
It's true.
People out here in Hollywood,
man,
I have the fucking trade magazines at my fingertips.
I know people who are on television,
they tie,
you get the inside information here.
I can't believe I'm ranked 52 with some of these gems that I'm giving you this
week.
It really boggles my mind.
I'm going to say I'm going to,
I'm going to crack the top 50 this week.
I'm going to get to number 49.
What do you think about that people,
um,
I,
what the hell I'm talking about.
This one's just going to be all momentum people.
All fucking momentum.
Uh,
let's,
let's talk about the Superbowl,
shall we?
It's shut off right out of the gate.
My condolences to Pittsburgh.
Steeler fans was a hell of a fucking game.
Little bit boring and points.
But,
uh,
I think some of that was had to do with the both teams had great defenses and
the fact that Ben Roethlisberger was wearing one sneaker and one moon boot or
was that an Ugh,
I don't know what happened.
I don't know what happened to that guy,
but I didn't realize that he was so fucked up before the God damn game.
But uh,
my condolences and congratulations to the Green Bay packers,
ladies and Gentlemen Are Fourth Super Bowl Championship.
Okay?
Combining that with nine NFL titles.
All right?
In three league titles,
giving them an overall total of 16 titles are right.
Nobody can fuck with that in professional football in America.
All right,
shut up.
You can see over there in Europe.
All right,
we call football football over here.
Even though we had the brains to pick the fucking thing up set our Ra's skipping
around fucking unbelievable.
Okay.
You over there in Europe,
they always give you shit on me.
Like,
well,
you know,
while you call it football might yell.
He knew you fucker for shut up.
You do use your foot when you kick a field goal.
And when you fucking kick off or you when your punt.
All right.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's was called foot and hand balls.
How,
what the fuck was [inaudible]?
How come you don't call it foot in head ball?
How come you don't call it that?
You use your fucking head over there too,
don't ya?
All right.
This smarty pants.
Um,
anyways,
sorry.
16 fucking titles.
All right.
That is their 16th title.
Saw You people there,
uh,
around the fucking league who keep looking.
I don't know.
And nobody,
I asked this question why they don't count NFL fucking titles and nobody gave me
a decent explanation.
They raise good people fucking shut back.
Then I got shit like that.
I got shit like urge because [inaudible] merger,
dumb shit like that.
Right?
That just made a lot of sports guys perk their fucking ears.
So yeah,
that is right that he's white.
He's because the merger is it,
is that why?
It is,
it's a fucking stupid reason because nobody else did that when they had a
merger.
You know,
the NHL had six teams for fucking ever in 1967 they added the expansion.
Six,
they doubled the size of their fucking league.
No other league has done that in one year ever.
Okay.
They didn't tell Montreal and Toronto to go fuck themselves with all their cups.
Montreal used to win him back.
You know when they used to play in a pond and the Stanley Cup was the size of
like a fucking shot glass.
They count those.
The fucking Chicago cubs have been waiting since 1907 I don't fucking understand
it.
It's bullshit.
Okay.
And later on in this podcast,
I'm,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm gonna read it right now.
All right.
This is basically how it went down.
And I know why you all you fucking sports nerds out there by the way.
I want you guys to debunk my,
my,
my way of thinking here.
Okay.
Cause you look at the Los Angeles Lakers to,
or their NBA championships are not even,
they weren't even one in the NBA.
Yeah.
They were one in a league called the BBA,
which then merged with some other that then became the NBA.
I mean,
you want to talk about padding your fucking stats.
You got every,
the Lakers can get away with that shit and act like they're one title away
from the fucking Celtics.
If they can get away with that horse shit with that Hanky that they put up with
five fucking titles on it.
Right.
It's funny.
Every other championship banner they have hanging on their wall,
it just says,
you know,
NBA champion,
1980 NBA champion,
1985 right.
They just have,
it's,
it's its own flag.
Then they got this one little fucking Hanky.
Okay.
Which should be a big slice of fucking toilet paper that they got five fucking
championships on.
I think shimp played on one of those God damn teens.
It's fucking ridiculous,
but if they can get away with that,
I'm telling you,
I'm counting from here on out.
I'm counting NFL titles.
All right.
I'm going to start a movement.
Okay.
If I can't close down the fucking Federal Reserve,
at least I can make this thing right in this goddamn country.
Okay.
Here,
here's how it goes.
All right?
Just if you want to know Green Bay's on top.
This is how it worked.
Okay?
1920s when the NFL starting,
all right,
from 1920 to 1932,
they had the league championship and it was determined by team wins and loss
percentages with ties admitted.
And then in 1932 because of a tie in the final standings,
a playoff game was played to determine the championship.
And from 1933 on that was called the NFL championship game,
all right?
That's how it fucking worked.
Okay?
Okay.
And all these teams,
including the fucking Steelers played,
played back then.
So they had an opportunity to win titles,
which they did not.
So here we go.
Here's how it goes down.
The most successful team.
So back then,
all right.
Uh,
the Green Bay packers,
they won nine NFL championships in three league titles for a total of fucking
was at 93,
the one 12th.
Um,
fuck it.
I didn't put these in in,
in,
uh,
any sort of chronological order here.
So I just got to read them.
The cults,
one for NFL Championships.
All right.
And,
and then another two Superbowls.
So they got six total.
The giants won New York giants,
New York football giants,
one for NFL titles plus three Superbowls.
So they got seven,
they get seven fucking championships.
You know,
this sitting there walking around like they only got three,
like to hang in there with my patriots then that they got twice as many as us
plus one Chicago bears won nine NFL fucking championships plus one Superbowl for
grand total of a,
of 10.
Uh,
the cardinals,
I've lost,
this is why I'm ranked number 52.
I've lost so many listeners at this point,
but I don't give a fuck.
Chicago cardinals,
which then became the Saint Louis Cardinals,
which then became the Arizona cardinals.
They won one league in one NFL title.
And if you want to go to an Arizona cardinals game,
and if you want to fucking chance a year at those fucking retired George
Mcgovern,
Republican cunts,
uh,
1947 that's the year you want to chant it.
Damn.
1947 right?
The lines one for NFL championships,
I forget when their last one I have the wrong year.
Written down was 1950 [inaudible] Cleveland Rams,
which then became the La rams in 1946 and then became the Saint Louis Rams in 19
fucking 95 I know,
I sound like the rain man.
They have one three NFL championships plus one super bowl for grand total of
four.
Here's my favorite one in the Cleveland browns they want for NFL titles.
All right.
And before that they want for all American football conference titles.
And there were three teams that were in the All American football conference
that merged with the NFL in 1950 and I'm not counting those championships,
by the way,
the all American football conference.
I wouldn't count those because that wasn't in the NFL.
That would be like the Lakers counting those BBA fucking championships.
Um,
the all American football constant conference existed from 1946 to 1949 they had
four championship games and the fucking Cleveland browns when all four,
they dominated that league.
That league merged with the NFL in 1950 and they took three teams with them.
The browns,
the cults,
and the 40.
Niners.
All right,
we're continuing and we've got a couple more here.
The Philadelphia Eagles,
one,
three,
three NFL titles.
Last one's 1960.
That's what you want a chance at those angry bastards.
And then good luck to you after that.
40 niners one zero and five Superbowls.
Steelers one zero NFL titles and have six Superbowls.
So they,
you go for all you sports nerds out there.
That's the deal.
All right?
So I don't want to fucking hear any of this.
Any acting like those things don't count.
They do count.
That was the best of the best back then.
And they went through the same bullshit as every other fucking league with.
Oh,
but they didn't let black guys play back then.
So what,
so what?
Every other sport counts,
those fucking things.
So,
um,
I didn't want to Hell my God damn point was,
but uh,
you know what I did want to read to continue with,
I'll get back to the stats in a minute,
but can I,
Hey,
can actually bring up something here about the super bowl.
Um,
what was going on with the beginning
of the game to share with those fucking whaling whores that they brought out to
sing every song that,
that ever about America.
You know,
they brought up that shit from fucking glee who tried to make America the
beautiful,
sexy.
Well,
wait,
what does it oh or singing amazing Grace May zing grays.
They get the little as a slide,
the fucking line.
All right.
She should have been booted right in the box and Christina Aguilera,
right then she comes out with terror booze face.
Say.
That's why I let,
I've been laying off the booze man.
That's it right there.
That's not baby weight.
Alright.
That chick likes her bear.
She came out there and uh,
I loved her though.
I liked how she sorta freestyle the national anthem.
You know what I mean?
Who can honestly remember those words unless you're singing it with somebody
else.
That's a really difficult thing to do.
She was just out there,
stars then the free flow
and could talk.
Let's go to oh,
sheltered else American.
Okay.
And the flag was still there.
Um,
so what,
I mean,
how long did that,
you know,
what kills me was I looked on my cable thing and it said Super Bowl pregame.
All right.
Out here,
the super bowl comes on at three in the afternoon.
So I see from fucking like 12 noon to like three is to pregame.
I don't want to see that shit.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a shit.
I don't really see these people break down the game.
The keys to the game.
I could give a fuck.
All right.
They're never right.
I don't give a shit.
I just don't care.
So I'm like,
okay,
the game starts at three and then I go to put it on.
And what do they have more of this pomp and fucking circumstance and I don't
like how they got to sing like 58 songs about fucking,
I understand that it's in America.
Okay.
It's obnoxious.
Jesus Christ with the fucking songs and then the,
and then they got to make them laugh every time you think that done,
they got to add a couple who had to the fucking line and you just sit in there.
Yeah,
I don't get it.
It's the most important game of the NFL season and they just drag out one douche
bag after another.
It has nothing to do with the game ended by the time the game starts.
It's like,
I don't even give a shit.
Um,
but at least Deion Sanders dressed up for the game.
Jesus Christ.
Man,
that guy really was showing his age.
How can you be that flashy and fuck up that bad?
You know what I mean?
It was like he picked out that shirt and tie and right before he went out there,
somebody spilled coffee all over it.
I think he had like a white suit and then he just went to the nearest like tire
salesman.
Hey,
you know,
once you give me,
uh,
just give me this brown suit and I'll just put it over.
This,
uh,
is candy came striped shirt with the fucking tie.
Um,
anyways,
let me,
let me get,
let me get to some stats.
The past fucking week here.
I actually,
I actually took the Steelers in the over just cause I knew everyone was going to
pick the packers and the under.
I don't even know what the fuck was.
I lost 25 bucks.
That was my big thing.
You know what?
This is the first time the fucking podcast officially hit a goddamn speed bump
here.
All Right,
Bill,
I'm emailing you.
So we didn't my stats last week,
how many times I said fuck on the podcast.
This is pretty staggering.
So bill,
I email,
I'm emailing you to inform you that I served as your personal status Titian
statistician during your previous podcast on January 31st,
2011.
I documented each and every time you said the word fuck or some variance of the
word,
I must say,
you are in a goddamn league of your own.
Thank you.
Uh,
you're the podcasting f bomb dropping equivalent of fucking wilt Chamberlain in
1962.
Um,
all right,
let's get to,
um,
anyways,
he said,
uh,
it's kind of ironic that a patio on the back in a way for this feat because th
through a little research I discovered that you used to pride yourself on a
clean bit during the early stages of your career.
Yeah,
I did.
I had to figure out if I could be funny without Carson.
Now once I proved to myself that I could,
I was then free to be myself.
Um,
who's a cozy smug country.
despite that fact,
he said it's obvious that you're off the wagon and fucking shit up on a whole
nother level.
Nowadays your numbers are fucking astonishing.
You might as well throw on some red,
red leather pants and a gold chain cause your volt,
you're vulgarity is reminiscent of Eddie Murphy's,
uh,
in the 1980s,
you transparent bastard.
I'll list a few of your milestones below and then elaborate on just how
revolutionary earth shattering your last podcast was.
All right.
This is actually,
I was kind of amazed by this.
Uh,
first usage of the word fuck occurred.
38 seconds into the podcast.
You hit the century mark.
17 minutes in this stat is mind boggling to me.
It took you little old,
a little over the equivalent of one quarter of football to drop a hundred f
bombs.
You did this almost leisurely too.
You're a fucking juggernaut.
I can only imagine the damage you do while watching a real quarter of football,
all sauced up on the juice.
So anyways,
I guess I,
I,
uh,
last week my podcast was 73 minutes and I said the f word 347 times.
Jesus Christ.
You used roughly a year's worth of cuss words in a little over an hour.
Come on,
dude.
If you use the word,
there's no way you say it once a day.
Um,
all right.
That's 4.753 uses per minute.
You make Andrew dice clay and Bob Saget stuff.
Look PG 13,
I'd argue that first half breakdown in the first 36 and a half minutes.
I used it 210 times and the second half,
137 look at that.
I slowed down after the all star break.
Everybody thought I was going to be the first guy to break 400 and I didn't.
Um,
so this guy actually uh,
made a graph of it.
First of all,
if I can figure out how to download this shit I downloaded,
I can't find it on my computer.
He has the marker with next to was the sharpie with his headphones and all that.
Like he's counting off days in prison,
345 little slashes there in groups of five.
And then he compared me to some of the most vulgar movies of all time.
Um,
uses per minute.
I beat out Casino Martin Lawrence Live Goodfellas,
menace to society.
Eddie Murphy delirious,
the big Lebowski and pulp fiction and then total counts of movies.
I came in second behind casino,
but in my defense that's like a two hour movie.
So fuck them.
Um,
there you go.
Is that enough stats for you in the first 20 minutes?
Jesus Christ can be ranked like 700 at this point.
Um,
so anyways,
what the hell was my,
uh,
my week,
like I got over my road aids just to let you guys know I got over it.
Ah,
yeah.
I don't know.
It just kept getting worse till like Friday and uh,
it's all cause I forgot my vitamins.
I told you guys that I booked some acting work right for tomorrow.
So what do I do?
I'm getting ready for the Superbowl.
Okay.
My Pay Patriots got beaten by the jet,
so I don't give a shit.
Um,
and I know I said it wouldn't trach rex Ryan,
but for some reason I couldn't resist and I had to watch his post,
uh,
game,
lost to the Steelers speech.
A just,
you know,
it just drove me nuts.
He was like,
you know,
a lot of people are gonna want to criticize us and they can,
but you know,
they don't have,
they don't have any right.
I,
it's just why don't they have a right,
he's like,
just change been through a lot.
Yeah.
You created most of it with your shit-talking.
You Shit talked the whole world the whole fucking year.
And you also said you were going to win the Superbowl.
You run it the side of the bus and you didn't.
Why do you feel people don't have a right to give you shit at that point?
It's fucking annoying in your gear yet.
Oh good.
You had the shame you,
it's going to be the shame.
I'll have the same goal.
You know what I hate about that con is one year he's finally going to win it and
be like,
dude,
what?
I say what I say?
You know what you said,
rex?
The same thing you say every fucking day.
So stop acting like you called it.
I can't stand that shit.
It drives me nuts.
You fucking wrong.
Just be a man about it and be like,
yeah,
I talked a lot of shit this year and I was fucking wrong.
So I'm here to take my medicine,
you know,
such a fucking fat bitch.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm getting ready for the,
I'm getting ready for the Superbowl and I don't give a fuck.
Writes the Steelers.
It's the packers.
I don't give a shit.
I ain't give a flying fuck about this game.
You know,
I don't,
I don't care.
Neither one of those teams I've ever done anything really to the Patriots.
I guess the packers beat us in [inaudible] 97,
but who gives a fuck?
We weren't supposed to win that game.
That was Brett Farve.
Remember that young Brett Farve,
he had brown hair and then he threw that first touchdown pass and he took his
helmet off and ran.
And when,
hey,
over to the sideline,
you remember that?
And they actually had to make a rule that you can't do that anymore because he
was so blatantly trying to get some sort of national commercial.
Ooh.
Um,
he,
I'll tell he just loves the game.
That guy just loves playing a game.
Oh.
How funny was it when the big Lebowski guy with the fucking most insane mustache
ever when he did those voiceovers people of Pittsburgh,
are you tired of them acting like people still work in steel mills out there?
You know,
cause I have to admit,
as a fan from Boston,
anytime they do anything about New England,
they show a lighthouse and a fucking lobster fishermen.
And I lived there for 27 years and I never met anyone who worked in a fucking
light house,
ran a lighthouse or even worked on a fucking lobster boat.
Nobody,
you know.
And I didn't like clam chowder.
I thought it looked like a,
it just looked like a curdled milk.
Get Out.
Look Gross.
I didn't like it.
But you know,
they're just sitting there talking about Pittsburgh going,
Eh,
Pittsburgh.
Pittsburgh's a tough town built on steel and when you're in Pittsburgh,
if you get hit by a bus,
she mother calls you a Faggot,
right?
Sorry,
got a little bit of the aids left.
Um,
I fucking hate that shit.
And then they go up
big green basis.
Same Shit is itself welcome place.
People used to pack shit,
hope and greed it green bay when there's pack and it'd be done.
You don't have to look too far to find somebody to pack.
So
did you know,
I just wish there would be more honest.
You know
there's place used to have a bunch of steel mills.
Now they all closed down and they're all rusted and half of them got turned into
malls.
Now there's a bunch of half fag sitting in cubicles looking at spreadsheets of
Wisconsin.
You got a bunch of fat fucks that are the God damn fucking pasty and they got
read shit on their face from the God damn cold.
And she had been packed up here since 40 years.
Nafta there a bunch of cheesy and fat flux.
This is all like that for the love of God.
Let the packers weird.
Why don't they do shit like that?
Could they do that?
Then I'd watch it then I wouldn't have it on fucking mute.
You know,
it'd be a nice break between whaling whores singing songs about America.
My is a fee
that diva shit.
Ah,
cause Christina Aguilera.
How about some PNID ex baby.
Good Lord.
I don't give a fuck.
She had a kid.
You still in your 20s go hit the fuck a treadmill.
What happened?
You know,
that's the danger.
That's the danger.
You know?
That's why I'm so glad you know.
I had a choice at some point in my career to become a sex symbol and I was just
like,
you know what?
I'm not going to do it.
You know,
cause there's only one way to go.
Just go down.
I did people,
I actually had the opportunity
to become Hollywood's first male redheaded sex symbol.
All right.
I know what you're thinking.
What about that fucking pasty freckled ass count who was on on end?
Ypd Blue fucked his whole career up.
What about that guy?
I have been in this business since before he fucked up his career.
Do you understand that people,
do you realize on March 2nd I am going to be celebrating my 19th year of
traveling to strip malls,
making people laugh,
giggle at my little wacky view of the world.
It's pretty fucking depressing.
I can't believe it,
man.
I remember when I was,
when I was a fucking kid,
when I got in this business,
when I looked at some of them been doing it 17 years,
I used to look at him like,
dude,
fucking hang it up because it is over.
It is fucking over.
You are not making it buddy.
Okay.
Maybe that's why you sweat and right through your fucking sport coat.
Jesus.
I started in 1992 that's right.
So if there was a 17 year fucking veteran,
not Jesus,
I gotta do math now.
That would be there.
That would mean they started in 1975 if I worked with somebody in 1992 when they
started in 1975 I would bitch be like,
dude,
wow.
Yeah.
What was that like?
What was it like?
You know?
Yeah.
Drive into,
you know,
I don't know what the fuck you guys did back then.
Flying on planes with propellers.
What,
what happened?
And now I don't know what happened.
I'm 19 years into this shit
and I realize now why those guys,
17 years,
it didn't quit because when you have a 17 to 19 year gap in your resume,
you know from the last time you actually had a day job,
excuse me.
Um,
yeah,
you're done.
No,
no one's going to hire.
What are you going to hire me to do?
Sell cars.
Okay.
All right.
What you been doing since 1992 I was kind of was kind of a cunt.
I have three and a half years of podcasts where I say some of the most horrific
shit ever.
There was any sort of corporate job.
Right?
Why the hell would I want to work for them anyways?
You know,
become part of the murder or whatever the fuck it is that you're doing.
There's always some sort of killing going on when you were for corporation,
you know,
it is if you follow it and then you sit there lying to yourself.
Well,
you know,
I just shine the gun.
I don't pull the trigger,
you know,
it's a fucking worst.
Um,
yeah.
So I've been doing it 19 years in,
there's really no turning back for me.
And,
uh,
if for some reason the bottom falls out,
I don't know what I would do.
I have no idea,
no fucking idea what I would do with,
which is why I don't think about this type of shit.
So I got 19 fucking years in.
That's unbelievable to me.
I remember when I hit 10 years in,
I was like,
Jesus,
I used to look at guys like 12,
13 years in when I had like eight.
Got Man,
they've been doing it a while.
They have to make it now.
They've been a make it now a is fucking over.
Um,
so I don't want them saying,
you know,
which probably brings up the question,
you like,
Bill,
do you think you made it?
Like what is it that makes you feel like,
you know what I think I did.
I did right.
The fuck
I didn't have high look,
I must fucking see student.
Okay.
So my goals aren't that high.
I look at it like I made that book glee this week.
Oh Shit.
I gotta get a puppet people.
I got to do it,
man.
I got to make it.
I have one year to make it.
If I don't fucking make it in the next year at 20 fucking years in,
I'll tell you right now,
you better build an extension to your Goddamn cubicle people cause I'm showing
up now.
I can't do it.
I left the program.
I'm like fucking uh,
uh,
what's his Marlon Brando's character in a pop apocalypse now?
I'm all the way up the river.
It's over already.
Got Ahead on the stick.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way I could ever go back and get a real job.
I'd have to have a kid and be like,
I'm doing it for him or her.
Right.
That's the only way I could,
there's no fucking way I could go in there and have somebody.
Oh,
Bill.
Oh my noticed you came in at nine oh eight this morning.
Yeah.
Did you,
did you notice anything else?
Like how fucked up that tie is you have like immediate,
I would just go to that actually.
I wouldn't,
yeah,
look at me trying to paint myself like I'm a bad ass.
I wouldn't,
I'd be like,
Oh yeah.
So I immediately go into that.
Sorry.
Traffic and you
know,
just become that guy and hate myself and take it out on some sweet lady of work
next to me has been with the company for 25 years.
You know,
she's never missed a day.
Yeah,
it's cause she's stealing from the company.
You'd dumb fucks.
Um,
she's too afraid to take a day off.
You have think about that.
All right,
let's get,
let's get to some topics there.
So once again,
congratulations to the Green Bay packers.
All right.
Up there in Green Bay,
when you live off one of the Great Lakes,
you better take your Dick and wrap it around your balls because they're,
they ain't no room for pussies.
Sorry.
Um,
I bet it saved my voice.
See this is,
this is the type of self sabotage and that's been part of my career for the last
19 years.
I do shit like this.
I should,
you know what?
I should just be thinking of myself and say fuck you guys in the 52nd rank
podcast on iTunes and I should be resting up on my voice.
That's what I should be fucking doing it.
But I'm not,
I'm not,
this is,
this is what I,
you know,
I don't know why I just up,
I thought,
oh,
I,
this is my thought I had.
So I'm getting ready to go super bowl,
right.
I don't give a fuck about any of the team I,
so I'm going to go make a couple of burgers.
So I've been using this natural goddamn charcoal,
which is great.
Doesn't have that chemical shit on it.
You know,
you know that shit when you're really hungry.
If he ever used that,
that match light stuff,
he just throw the Patty on too early.
You taste the lighter fluid fluid in,
in,
in your burger.
Um,
so I'm using the natural stuff,
which takes longer to light and it's more of a pain in the ass when you get down
to the bottom of the bag.
The pieces are too fucking small or he got one giant piece.
So I take out one giant piece.
It's like I'm not breaking this mother fucker up.
Long story short,
I couldn't get any sizzle,
a mag residual.
All right.
Then I'm starving.
So my girls,
I night,
well,
why don't we just make it,
why don't we just make it on,
on the,
on the stove top.
And it's like,
I'm like,
because I'm a man.
That's why,
because I can't admit defeat.
I can't admit the fact that what I'm doing.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing right now.
All right?
So I just added more fuel to the damn fire.
So then they throw these fucking patties on
is what I do.
And uh,
I make these two fucking things.
I melt the cheese and I think everything's going on right now,
but I'm doing it like I had some sizzle on my grizzle.
You like that?
That's where a little hip hop,
not for this week.
And evidently I didn't.
So I,
I,
you know,
rather than cutting in and making sure everything was done,
it didn't,
I just take these motherfuckers off.
Okay.
And they're like the size,
you know,
twice the size and Mcdonald's Burgers,
it just little ones.
I don't give a fuck.
Right.
So I take it off the grill.
I put one I put on my pervious,
which it's just ketchup and pickle.
I keep it fucking simple.
All right.
Slice the motherfucker and half and I look in the inside of it looks like raw
meat and immediately my brain goes,
don't eat that shit.
Okay,
you're going to get a coal lie.
You have to take glee tomorrow.
How can you sing with a deadly virus inside of you?
He just got overrode aids.
Okay,
let's not had a cold light to this for.
What do I do?
I don't give a fuck.
I just eat the goddamn thing,
you know,
eat the fucking thing.
I smell like smoke.
I got,
I'm taking a shower and I'm in that just waiting for this feeling of fucking
death.
You know?
Fortunately it never hit me,
but you know why?
Why?
Why would I do something like that?
Self sabotage stupid,
you know?
That's why I never booked an episode of Caroline in the city.
I mean I booked one,
but I uh,
you know I fucking night I got salmonella.
Um,
all right.
You know what people that story went nowhere.
I'm up.
I apologize.
So you know what?
I think it's time to bring a guest onto the show.
I'm going to hit pause here on the recording cause I got to set up the
microphone.
We're going to bring my lovely girlfriend in and she's going to contribute on
this week's version of um,
is it racist,
racist,
racist?
Yes.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it is time.
Once again for,
is it racist,
racist,
yes.
And this time,
this time I am joined by my lovely girlfriend,
Nia.
How are you sweetheart?
I'm great sweetie.
How are you?
Fantastic.
Let's not be too nice to each other because of my listeners.
You know,
I find out this week I'm ranked 52nd on the podcast in iTunes.
Out of how many?
Like 63?
No,
I don't,
I don't know how many there are.
I know everybody has a plot here getting their baby.
See that?
All right,
well here we go.
We're gonna,
we're gonna,
we're gonna bring you in here and uh,
and I,
you know,
you gotta hand it to me,
Huh?
Um,
you know for what?
Well,
you know,
I booked glee this week.
Oh,
that's right.
I know.
I'm so excited about that.
And now I'm nervous about my dancing.
I'm all right with my singing,
but the,
the,
no,
we've been working on your pot of arrays,
so I have felt pretty confident.
Fuck that.
And here we go.
All right.
Uh,
this guy wrote from a Byu.
Are you familiar with Byu?
Brigham Young University?
This is the Mormon.
You know those people,
right?
Sure.
Big gloves.
Yeah,
they're wild and out out there.
Right while and out while it out.
They have like 12 wives each skirts down to their ankles,
gorgeous.
Down to their ankles and they don't call us up to their right shin.
Yeah.
And they're all virgins before they get married vaginally.
Right.
They just have anal [inaudible].
That's how they do it.
That's,
you tie everybody that the salt flats and you've seen that fucking sit.
Oh,
it's that state.
All right.
Byu,
is this racist?
He says,
Bill,
is it racist to root for Byu?
This is the college because they have the best scorer.
Glen Falls,
finest white boy.
Uh,
they start four white kids in total and our eighth in the note in the,
because I do so evidently this guy's white and he's rooting for,
uh,
this white basketball team.
Basically they start four white guys and one of the higher,
the number one scores and eleague is white and he's white.
Is it right?
Is it racist?
Racist.
Because why don't you just use the effect of your garage band?
Because it takes too much fucking time.
Um,
plus I think it sounds better.
Racist.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
See,
I can do it.
Um,
is it racist that a white guy is white for white people on a white team full of
white people doing white things?
Plain white beliefs?
Plenty basketball?
No,
it is not racist.
Is Not Racist.
Okay.
And what?
Cause it,
it has nothing to do with race.
It's not like he's saying that God has everything to do with race.
Like he's saying like,
you know,
fuck black people,
they can't play basketball.
Right.
There's white people,
white people own,
that's what it is.
You know that it's not like that.
He just likes the white people.
I,
this is what,
this is what I think.
I think if you,
if your people traditionally suck at something or have been prevented from doing
something,
then it's okay for you to root for your guy.
Okay.
Now that is nobody prevented what people from playing basketball.
We just sort of sucked at it for a while.
I don't understand why cause we can't jump.
No,
no,
no.
I'm,
I don't understand why he thinks that that would even be in the racist category
because we get in trouble for everything because he's rooting for a,
he's like,
I like this team.
I'm rooting for them,
but I don't want people thinking,
think I'm racist.
No,
it's because,
look,
if you're fucking 30 years or younger,
you don't even remember white people doing a 40 years or younger,
you don't remember was dominating any fucking spot other than hockey.
Right.
All right,
and we're starting to creep in on that a little bit that you know what
black people,
it's like,
well,
Bronwyn,
Lebron talks about the scoring title.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Well,
you don't watch sports,
but like Lebron was just like one time they were asking him about the scoring
title and they were like,
you know what?
Anything about Colby.
And he said,
look,
if I wanted to,
if I want it to,
I could win that fucking thing.
But he's trying to,
like,
when I look at,
I look at hockey the same way,
like a black people want it to,
if you want it to,
if we get dominated hockey,
you could,
I don't know,
you know?
I mean,
how many,
how many more sports examples do you need?
How many more sports do you have to fucking take over before you just sort of
realize,
you know,
you killing it.
Yeah.
Now that,
that,
that is not racist.
I don't think it's phrased as either because we've been getting dunked on for
fucking,
yeah.
I,
he wants to rule for white people.
That's not racist.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So there we go.
That's,
that's the first one.
All right,
next one.
This is,
this is a good one here.
Uh,
racism or ethnic,
then I have to fucking no ethnicity.
That's not what I did this after the Superbowl.
I got e coli and covering from road eights here.
Bill a bit listening to your recent podcast about racism ahead.
Had a few questions.
Uh,
pop in my head.
Why do they call your background,
your ethnicity?
Example?
Spanish,
African American,
Chinese.
But why?
When we tee someone's ethnicity,
it's called racism.
Maybe it should be called ethnicity or ethnicity.
I don't know what he's basically saying.
There is a why if I guess if you go,
I don't like those German motherfuckers.
Why would that be considered racist and shouldn't that be,
that would be more of an ethnic thing.
Cause they are,
they are a certain brand of white people.
I honestly don't know.
I understand this question.
No,
no.
I think I'm a little stumped too.
Like I don't know that I know that the difference necessarily between ethnicity
and race.
All right.
Well why don't I know that.
I don't know why,
will tell me.
Okay.
Well
races like,
like a would be like,
um,
uh,
here we go.
Uh,
black people,
white people like look,
people from people from England,
France,
Germany,
all of them.
Those are white people.
Ethnicity,
but like your ethnicity as German?
Irish.
I'm German,
Irish,
Scottish,
English and French.
My hunch city is like African and like a small,
small drop of native American or something.
You Go,
okay.
So what was your price?
Racist.
Black I guess basically or African American,
whatever the fuck you fill out.
Right.
I guess you say it a lot of times that uh,
I don't know what the fuck he's saying.
I think he's saying like if someone like was given shit about Irish people,
they say it's racist or something like that.
Oh,
you're making fun of the ethnicity.
God,
you know,
cause you're not trashing all white people,
right.
You're just,
you're just complaining about a certain ethnicity as opposed to entire race of
people.
Caucasian versus Irish or something.
Yeah.
I don't fucking know what,
I'm trying to get some fire on this topic
too.
Fucking artists.
You just agree with all of this shit.
I'm not agreeing with it.
I just,
I don't know why they,
I don't know why that it's called that either.
Well you thought my older Asian game that I play,
you said that that was racist,
right?
Yes.
How,
how is that racist?
Not The old part.
That's ageist.
Right?
But um,
yeah,
cause you said that all Asian people can't drive.
I don't,
I didn't.
Yes you did.
What did I say that you always say that I didn't,
I said if somebody fucks up in front of me,
those are the two.
I'm guessing you don't see how that's or Asian,
you don't see how that you're,
you're like one group of people and stereotyping them.
Yes,
I'm definitely stereotyping them.
Oh,
I see.
But what you're saying is that you're not lying.
I'm not saying ain't Asians are bad people that Ah,
yeah,
just saying that they can't drive.
So your stereotype in the quest and makes a fucking,
you turn on a highway if it's not an 85 year old guy,
if you had to take your life savings,
I'm not even saying it's going to be an Asian guy.
So what if you had to bet,
right?
And if your life was on the fucking line telling you I know what I know in the
grand question of his bill burr racist against Asians,
I would say no,
but he does stereotype them really,
really bad.
And who's fault is that?
Yours?
No one isn't.
Do you think I just pulled that out of it?
If someone said that white people can't jump,
do you think they just pull that out of their fucking ass?
Don't how many fucking white guys do you have to watch?
How many six foot 10 inch white guys do you got to watch slam the ball under the
front of the rim.
It almost dislocate their shoulder trying to dunk on a fucking break away before
you can say white people can't jump.
Did you go and you go on youtube and you'll see some white dudes doing some shit
white people could do.
Right.
You think you're think there are the exception and not the rule.
I'm just saying that if somebody said to me who wasn't white said white guys
can't jump and they can't fucking dance,
I'm really not going to get into a heated debate about that.
Right.
I'm sure Donny Osmond can cut a fucking rug with John Travolta or whoever the
fuck you want to talk to him in federal line.
He was a dancer.
Yeah,
that's it.
That doesn't count before he became a meme,
but it wasn't though.
He hung up.
He hung out with black people and he did hip hop.
He bought one of those
video.
He had corn rows.
Yeah.
And he liked to bang black girls.
That doesn't count.
It doesn't fucking count.
Timberlake.
I mean stole Michael Jackson's voice and all the shit that Michael Jackson
actually stoled from Mimes and hip hop dancers
and James Brown.
James Brown.
There you go.
I don't fucking,
I'm just talking shit in here.
Um,
all right,
well I see the distinction,
but it's still,
it's still wrong.
What is wrong?
It's wrong of you to stereotype Asian people.
I'm not fucking hurting anybody.
It would get started off.
It started off as a joke in the fucking car.
I know that
does stand up.
Sit down now.
Unless you're going to use that finger,
I suggest you put it away.
Oh Shit.
Shit.
That's from like second grade.
What do you have on boots right now?
It's really annoying.
Why are you in your underwear?
You want to talk shit cause it's fucking 10 o'clock at night and I'm in my own
goddamn bedroom.
If you were going outside,
that would make sense.
You're wearing tidy whities but they're black.
I don't know if these are,
these are like the snug ones.
They're like biker shorts.
They cut my balls and make them feel good.
What's wrong with that?
You said you like these and you were wearing your Boston Bruins yard.
I do like,
but you got a lot of nerve standing up pontificating and your underwear.
Why it areas?
It shows you how passionate and Emma,
but my opinions,
I want to bribe one of your listener.
So like send me something like an Amazon gift wish,
like a gift wishlist and then,
and I'll send them a picture of you right now as you are.
Can I do that?
Can I go ahead and do that?
That's the end of the year.
Fucking anytime you want to fucking have meals,
they don't need it at this point with technology.
They just take my hand picking on somebody anyway,
so that's true.
Yeah.
Which is what they're all going to do now.
Anything else you'd like to add Kim?
So you guys will somebody please do that.
Make composite of that and email it to bill.
Okay.
And you know what this is all about is I have too much control in the
relationship right now.
So this is what you do.
He's trying to get my listeners to turn on me.
Is that what it is?
Divide and conquer and making it funny.
I thought that's what I was looking for.
All right.
This is why I brought that shit up.
This is why stood up my underwear and I started pointing at you raising my
voice.
The fuck are we talking?
We were talking about that older agent thing.
Alright,
and it was one of the,
we were in the fucking car and you've,
you've admitted in the car,
you like Jesus Christ.
There's something to this game
and the
time when it was in a little odd,
that's the closest I'm ever going to get.
You admitted to your boss.
The best one was when it was an old Asian guy and that's what we came up like.
That was hitting green.
Double Zero in fucking a roulette.
You had to call old Asian.
Well,
it's rude.
I have a,
this is going to sound terrible,
but I have Asian friends so I don't want people to think that I sewed a why they
Kevin Shay,
Bobby Lee.
I love Bobby Lane.
You don't love Kevin Shay?
I don't know him.
Really.
Bobby,
Lebron.
Kevin Shay is like the angry Bobby Lee.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Got It.
Bobby Lee's anger.
It's just somewhere hidden in there.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
And yet,
you know,
you know what this is.
This is right here.
This is why,
you know,
when you went home,
when you want to break balls,
you got to hang out with other guys because the woman's going to ruin it.
What about why you want to bring in a little mini bill birth and here just your
own opinion.
Regurgitated over and over again.
Why don't you get bored with that audio of a crowd applauding underneath it.
Bill's always right.
Give me another,
is it racist?
All right,
well,
I have to look up one.
You really do.
You realize I said the f word 347 times.
That is incredible.
Even for you.
Really,
Jesus Christ.
You just really abandoning me,
aren't you?
I'm
not,
but that's excessive.
Yeah.
This podcast,
beard as excessive.
You're the one who told me to fucking grow it.
I love it.
He told me to grow a God damn beard.
And guess what?
You got a part on glee because of it.
And it's right.
I'm playing the part of Kenny Loggins.
All right.
These are the ones that I'm just grabbing these,
Eh,
uh,
I don't know where.
Okay.
Uh,
okay.
And this,
this was your fucking idea too,
cause some of these get crazy.
All right,
Bill,
I'd like to,
it's your fault.
I'd like to use your,
is it racist segment to get a ruling on a dispute between myself,
a white guy and some friends?
The issue involves,
uh,
the,
the issue in question revolves around a particular Halloween costume of mine a
few years back.
You chose this one near,
here we go.
Anyway.
Uh,
anyone who's been to Vegas knows about the porn slappers that clog up all the
sidewalks on the strip.
I guess it was the guys who hand out the flyers,
I guess.
I have no idea.
I'm so calls because as they're handing out the stripper,
our US business cards,
they give him a quick snap on the hand shoving them in your face.
Okay.
As if having full color porn pushed on you while trying to walk down the street
wasn't enough.
I guess they deem it necessary to violate your auditory senses as well while
they got to get you to pay attention.
All right.
Um,
during a routine trip,
I'm sorry that that slapping of the card that reminds me of,
remember when we went to jumbos clown room and that girl,
when we,
when we first went in there,
the stripper was like super friendly as you walk in and then occasionally you'd
hear like,
like a clapping noise really loud cause sound like somebody got shot and it was
her clapping her,
her stripper boots together trying to get your attention and cause the room was
too quiet and no one's paying attention to her.
It was so pathetic in there and all of a sudden it sounded like a gunshot.
It was clapping.
Her fucking
stripper quit on.
Exactly.
Anyway,
she didn't like say,
I'm never dancing get,
she just stopped dancing.
She crawled over on her hands and knees to her purse,
lied on her stomach,
pulled her phone out and started texting onstage,
still
going titties out with the Thong on.
But the best part was she,
uh,
she danced through the whole first song yeah.
And didn't make one dime.
It was slowly coming down the pole,
grade his love of all and then whatever the hell it and then landed on her back.
Not One guy.
She was terrific.
She was ugly too.
And um,
the next song started and she was just laying there.
She didn't answer the bell,
like a fighter quit on the fucking school.
I had no respect for them.
Anyways,
let's go,
let's continue here.
Uh,
during a routine trip to Vegas,
noticing yeah.
How he paints himself as somebody innocent.
You know,
I thought it would be funny to dress up as a porn slapper for Halloween.
So while there I collected a sizable stack of the previously mentioned cards.
When I returned home I had a fluorescent pink stripper direct to you shirt,
made a,
had it made up an assembled with other key components to create what I consider
to be an authentic reproduction.
Is this going to end with him in blackface?
It's going to end with him and Mexican face or whatever.
Cause that's all the guys seem to be like Hispanic.
Handing those out.
I know where this is going.
Here's when the train went off the tracks and the claim
costume became racist.
My completed costume consisted of a straw cowboy hat,
short black wig,
brown facial makeup,
a large mustache stripper direct shirt,
so navy Dickies and tennis shoes.
Basically if Poncho villa to get a second job to pick up a little cash on the
side.
That's what I ended up looking like.
Now,
did any of my so called white friends mentioned that this costume might be
racist during the construction frayed or they so called white or are they still
called friends so called white branch?
Of course not.
They didn't say,
oh basically says white friends didn't say shit,
but the second I'm out on Halloween night,
suddenly I'm surrounded by spokespeople for the Anti Defamation League.
Dude,
where the fuck did you do this?
My stance in all of this was a yes that the costumers privately,
racially insensitive,
but it was not done to be malicious.
I was just shooting for authenticity and therefore it wasn't racist.
My friends claim that it was blatantly racist.
The friends who didn't say shit,
we're not trying to step away my friends so called white bread.
Can I please get your opinion on this?
Uh,
all right,
here's my question.
Did he have to,
he could've done that entire costume without the,
let's say brown face without the Brown face and people would have gotten it
because he'd be heading out those bank.
He'd be saying be,
you'll be like,
oh cause everyone's gone to Vegas.
Everyone's seen those.
I went to Vegas,
I brought you back a stack of those fucking cards cause I thought it was funny
and so people would have gotten it.
So it does seem a little excessive to add the brown face when it's really
unnecessary.
So he is,
he's dipping his toe in the racist pawn.
I do not think that this person is a racist human being.
I don't think he's like he,
he thinks Mexican people or be,
they shouldn't,
I shouldn't even say my skin.
They could be Peruvian,
whatever.
I don't think things are bad.
But he definitely dipped his toe in because there was really no need to go that
far.
He could have gotten the entire thing and everyone would have gotten it.
All right.
This is what I said he didn't need brown face
is what I say.
I say this isn't racist.
I say what he's guilty of is not knowing that he was going to be called a racist
because if every fucking due to hand in those things out that weekend was
Mexican and look like that and he went all out to try and look like that.
All he's guilty of is having a fucking kickass cost.
All right,
and if the way his brothers can make white chicks,
that fucking horrific horror that I fucking saw and I say it's up.
I didn't see the movie just like it was so fucking
weird that that just got to transvestite 80 for me when he took his foot out and
had it on the table,
it just really was fucking doesn't understand how air we're supposed to believe
that everyone in the movie doesn't realize that it's black people in white face
cause it's so hot.
I'm like,
do people really believe that isn't an a white person?
Like they're talking to other white people?
Like it doesn't look weird.
And this is my thing.
If you can fucking do that.
Okay.
Which I get,
I get the rules are fucking different because all the bullshit that's happening.
So that's one of those things where he's guilty of light,
like a white person who doesn't mean anything bad but says you people are you
guys?
Right?
And then has to be like,
what?
I didn't know.
I didn't fucking know.
So I,
I wouldn't
say that that's,
that's,
that's not racist.
It's,
it's just a,
but your friends are fucking sellouts who
I think they did it on purpose.
I think they were like,
oh,
this is going to be good.
They didn't have a purpose.
I think they wanted him to get called out.
If they did it on purpose,
then that's fucking it.
But yeah,
I don't think,
uh,
I think it was a little unnecessary to add that.
I don't think he needed that for the costume.
This is what I would say in a perfect world.
Right.
He had a great costume,
but because of all the shift that we've done,
you know,
that's just one of those,
one of those extra,
you know,
because of all the extra perks,
perks you get for being fucking white.
You know,
like you should see,
you should have seen the gift bag I got when I was born.
It was,
it was fucking ridiculous.
Yeah,
it was.
It was like a bag full of cash.
Oh yeah.
Subsequent life.
Your college was automatically paid for it.
You had a job set up.
Oh yeah.
We just bitch.
Cause no,
that's actually,
it's a,
you know,
I,
if I,
if I could tell you,
I don't honestly how difficult it is being white.
That's what I want and I want to know the why.
That's,
I'd be curious to know why he felt like he had it to add that to it.
He did.
Maybe he didn't feel like the,
the costume was like clear enough.
He's like,
I got everything.
You know what,
this needs penny.
He could even just left the mustache and not have to go.
It has a specific guy like Billy crystal.
Yeah.
Would he use to do Sammy Davis Jr on SNL was in,
he was not only in black face,
he was in black body,
black,
everything.
He wouldn't,
I mean obviously not underneath but like he and he somehow he got away with it
cause he was doing a specific guy like how does that work?
But then Ted Danson comes out and does a roast.
I mean I'm really going far back here,
which allegedly everything goes.
Did you see on 30 rock when they had one of the characters in blackface?
They had a much,
I don't want shit.
Shut up.
The girl that plays I Jane Krakowski.
It was really funny.
And then the context,
it made complete sense and it wasn't like,
all right,
well let me,
let me,
let me read one more.
Yeah.
And then,
and then we're going to let you go here now though.
Another stunning performance here.
Dear belt after listing,
how much better am I getting at reading out loud.
Okay.
You know what it is.
I do it now.
I'm getting way better at this for like a little kid.
I am.
What I do is when I start to sound it out,
take your time,
start to lose,
control the sentence.
Just make up whatever they're talking about.
After listening to all the racist stories from the last two podcasts,
I really like your comedy bill.
I have one.
Did they really say that?
No.
Okay.
I have one I wanted to share that I have always felt I lost.
Uh,
all right.
Back in the 10th grade,
I had a friend name Robbie.
Um,
he happened to be one of the five black people in my high school.
Oh Geez.
Here we go.
Yeah.
I knew him for a few years and we had a few classes together.
We both took some sort of technical drawing classes and sat next to each other.
After we became sort of friends,
he thought it was okay to call me cracker Hunky,
et cetera.
This must have been the 70s.
So if you broke out Hunky,
uh,
I'm pretty sure he stopped calling me by my real name and only by my racial
slurs in a while.
See how I'm white and I'm pretty laid back.
I didn't give a fuck about what he called me.
Yeah.
I mean,
at that point,
if every president was white at that point,
you don't give a shit.
It doesn't carry as much water.
So anyways,
after about two weeks of being bombarded with racial slurs,
see,
I don't even consider those racial slurs.
I just consider those,
you know.
Okay.
I,
I don't consider those ratios.
Yeah.
Hey white boy,
that doesn't bug me.
Okay.
Hey,
fucking black guy
does.
It does,
it doesn't bother me.
I don't give a shit.
Hey,
black guy.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
after about two weeks of being bombarded with racial slurs,
I figured I would,
I would say,
oh no.
Well,
okay,
thank him.
He started.
Yeah.
Yes.
You know what it means.
I figured that by saying it,
it would be all be in good fun and we would have a good laugh and it would be
over.
Oh,
I hope.
I hope he buried it in the middle of a sentence.
That's the only way.
If he had,
he needs a lot of words surrounding it.
Any better now to set it with the are,
here we go.
So one day a great opportunity came along when I walked in the room and Robbie
says,
what's up my cracker in my head,
I was telling myself to let her rip that's so close to get her done.
This isn't going to end good.
So while I'm doing some sort of stupid hand shape,
I replied to Robbie saying,
what's up my n word?
Instantly without hesitation,
Robbie's ancestral tribal warrior spirit kicked in.
Next thing I knew I was being manhandled by a black kid that was much bigger
than me.
Uh,
the scuffled didn't last long and nobody got hurt.
He said,
what's up my crack?
And then you said,
what's up my n word?
And that was a fun mats
that kind of seemed like the comedically that would flow.
Yeah.
And it would be like funny and everyone would be like,
everyone in school would be kind of like,
wow.
Like they have that kind of relationship that they can go back and forth like
that.
Well his actually sounds like a really bad sitcom.
It does.
All right,
let's finish.
Here we go.
After the fight,
we got into a twisted debate on how I was somehow wrong for what I said,
Eh,
that Robbie wasn't,
it was some,
uh,
with some complete bullshit,
like a bunch of pussies,
afraid of appearing racist.
None of the other white kids in my class had my back to this date.
Still Amaze me how sensitive people are when it comes to racist shit.
Robbie could clearly dish it out,
but he couldn't handle any,
uh,
heat directed toward him.
I didn't give a shit what he called me,
but,
uh,
shit right there.
I should have made up some shit.
I didn't give a shit when he called me because I knew he was just joking around.
When I started joke around with him,
he flipped out.
We still remained friends throughout high school.
To this day,
I feel as if I didn't do anything wrong,
but I still feel as if I lost the argument.
What do you think?
Uh,
I think that's one of those things where,
uh,
maybe because,
because it was too many other white people around,
but it was one of those things where he should have got at least two minutes for
instigating on that run.
You know,
what were they fighting?
One gets two minutes cause I can see where if they were in private they might've
said that to each other and laughed.
But if there's other people around then his friend feels like embarrassed and
humiliated and like,
oh you're letting this guy say whatever you want.
So you know,
but this is like,
this kind of like reminds me of when black people say that we shouldn't be so
casual about the n word because it makes white people think that you guys can
just say it to us because we say it to each other all the time.
Even the guys say to each other all the time.
I see what the big deal is,
rappers and stuff.
You guys were constantly saying it.
So it's like,
and now it's a problem if I say it.
Yeah,
clearly not the same thing.
However,
I do see that side of the argument where it's like,
well in a lot of it's from like older black people too that are like,
you know,
you can't keep saying it like that cause white people will think that we don't
respect ourselves and so they should neither blah blah blah.
Right.
Let me go back to the white guy.
Go,
well what you guys say do Joe Blow?
That's just a racist for the most part that's just a racist white guy.
Yeah.
Tried to acting is rationalize.
Yes.
Saying the n word.
I was trying to rationalize trying to get away with it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No.
Okay.
So I would say
pretty much that's what that is.
I never a,
I don't think his friend should have opened the door to use that kind of
language and I think his friend was kind of enjoying the phone.
I call him a cracker and Honky,
I think he liked that,
that he could just say that to him.
And it might've been like some sort of subconscious like yeah,
see I can say whatever I want and you can't say shit to me.
And then when he did it was like,
no,
you can't.
Which isn't exactly fair.
Well it depends on how
set it.
If you went a little high pitched and try to say it like funny,
I think he could've.
Yeah.
What's his face?
Do you impression of the peanut here?
How does he,
how does he always greet the black guy on it?
No,
no.
Say it.
Say The white people for,
we were like,
Hey Sharon.
He goes,
hey,
how you doing?
Villi?
How's it going?
Tommy looking good.
How you doing Nathan?
Oh,
fucking bad.
That's just embarrassing.
Um,
Oh,
speaking of embarrassing,
I asked last week who was the last white guy to win an NFL rushing title and I
actually got two interesting answers.
Okay.
The last time a white guy won it for the conference,
Mark Van Egan it for the AFC in 1977 but Walter Payton one,
the overall rushing title and Jim oldest one in 1975.
That doesn't sound like a white guy named does it.
Jim Otis,
uh,
flow either way with that one.
Yeah.
Oldest Anderson for the Saint Louis Cardinals.
He wanted and I think Oj Simpson one at that year,
uh,
speaking of white people,
I didn't know what he meant by that.
During his,
his,
uh,
the woman,
he fucking,
oh my God.
A debt to married to back when that verdict was read and we watched it.
We were watching it in high school and I went to,
you know,
pretty much an all white high school.
There was definitely some black people there,
but not as many as the way people are.
You guys like high fiving is every other white person faces
did it was weird.
Yeah,
it was a weird thing because it's like,
yeah,
we were watching it in class,
you know,
when we should have been learning,
but we're watching it in class and then so the verdict and the like,
you can feel them wanting to sell,
like wanting to be like no.
And then them looking at me and you know,
looking at maybe the other one other black Bustos and I remember this guy coming
up to me,
he goes,
listen,
I am not racist.
And I go,
oh Geez,
hold that white bitch.
But I think,
I think,
I think he should have gone to jail.
And I was like,
ah,
okay.
And I said,
well,
he's not,
and he goes,
well,
oh.
And then he just walks away and he walked away and then you probably mumbled
some other shit.
Um,
but he just felt the need to let me know.
Right.
Well that's one of those things where black people being happy where the say
that was just like the white guy rooting for Byu because they just,
you know,
white guys have not succeeded in basketball and you guys haven't done so well in
the trials.
Not so much.
Yeah.
Throughout history.
So it was less about the fact that he clearly did it then the fact that,
you know,
no he didn't because he wrote that book where he said if he was gonna do it,
everyone know what the book was totally different.
The book never even came out.
First pack of [inaudible] football
cards I ever got Oj Simpson was,
was the,
uh,
was the first one and I fucking loved the guy.
He betrayed you guys more than he betrayed us outlook,
which is the ultimate irony.
He,
I can't even say what I,
what,
how I feel about that shit,
but I'm going to tell you this,
there is actually a picture somewhere in the attic of my life of me in second
grade sitting on Santa clauses lap with an Oj Simpson Jersey
that says it all in a sticker on my hand because I had a good day at school or
some shit.
I don't know.
Oh,
I just remembered another example of,
uh,
well let me fit in a NSA black face.
Let me,
let me finish the rushing title and the last white guy to overall when a rushing
title like no bullshit was 1962,
Jim Taylor for the Green Bay packers and he wanted an in between,
uh,
Jim Brown.
I don't know what happened to Jim Brown that year,
but uh,
so he wanted,
so there you go.
That's essentially the pot.
Yeah,
it's a podcast for this week.
I got a rest up to do my daily this week.
Um,
you know what song I'm singing?
No,
what is it?
Ah,
I'm too embarrassed to even say,
you shouldn't say let it be a surprise.
Let it be a surprise.
All right.
None of when the tune in it's ugly on the glean network.
And we'll switch your last thing before I sign off here.
Cause I got to upload this shit.
No,
I'm just gonna I just wanted to talk about really quickly,
I had a boyfriend in college and
we had a great time.
Hey listen,
I know I do have a couple more.
Tufts,
I don't even know your fucking boyfriend
college.
No,
it has nothing to do with our relationship is when he was a little kid and he
was dressed as a hobo for Halloween.
He was white by the way.
Um,
and he put dirt on it.
Like he wanted to put like brown makeup on his face to look like dirt.
So He'd look like a dirty Hobo and it looked like
black.
Oh.
He went all out.
People were like,
do you think all black people are homeless?
And he was saying,
I just want to be dirty.
So it was,
which made it worse,
but it was hilarious.
Yeah.
Geez,
that's a funny story.
It really isn't.
No,
you know,
cause cause the fact that he told you that story,
I can see how far into the relationship you are,
which means other things were going on,
which I really didn't need to know.
All right,
here's one best teacher ever.
Listen to this guy.
This,
I got this from a teacher with the fuck was this guy when I was in high school.
Hey Bill,
first of all,
love your podcast and your stand up.
Thank you.
The reason why I'm writing to you is I'm a math teacher and I have a student
who's a class clown.
I really think he has the potential to be a great standup comedian and I want to
suggest that to him,
um,
as a potential future for him.
Um,
I don't think that academics is really his thing.
What would be some good things slash advice to show slash tell him,
right?
Rather than being the asshole teacher would be like you shut down,
shut your fucking mouth and make them clap.
The erases whatever the fuck these kids do nowadays.
Um,
this guy's actually,
I'm actually brought the guy back.
I said,
what?
I always say,
write five minutes of Shit you think's funny.
Sign up for an open mic.
When they call your name,
go up on stage and there you got.
Don't judge yourself the first 10 to 15 times you do it 10 times.
I would say it's all about being like,
wow,
I'm holding a microphone.
I'm really doing that.
They really do have brick walls behind me as you're trying to remember your
shit,
but after 10 times,
then you start getting a feel for it and then then you,
then everything else falls into fucking place.
They have a talent contest at a talent show at the school.
He should do it too.
Oh he shouldn't.
That's what I need to tell you.
Under no fucking circumstances,
should you ever go on stage.
The first time you ever did standup comedy in front of your own fucking class.
Oh my God.
Oh,
that's true.
Because if it doesn't go well,
it's going to be humiliating.
So he should do it somewhere else away from us so he can work it out.
So he doesn't bomb in front of all those friends.
Everybody's going to heckle you in that case,
your balls that that is like,
that's why like bombing on a cruise ship sucks because when you,
after you bomb,
you can't leave just with the crowd and everybody just sits there looking at you
and that that's at least a cruise is over in a week.
This kid's got to finish off the fucking school year.
But for the love of God,
if the teacher's listening do not tell him to sign up for a talent fucking
contest,
don't do that because that's the type of thing that could leave in emotional
scar with a kid.
Might not do it again for five years or never fucking do it again.
Okay.
You need,
okay.
You need an escape plan when you're going to go up and do that shit.
Believe me,
we're not the first time ever fucking bombed.
Oh my God.
Where was the fucking roof?
Where was the first time you bond in some fucking bar in uh,
uh,
north reading Massachusetts.
I want to say some place Kelly's or something doesn't even exist anymore.
And I walked in and there was this function,
this little half of the bar,
we could sit down and eat fucking fish and chips and there was like nobody there
other than other comedians.
And then like three fucking people who came to see another comedian and then up
at the bar with just guys drinking like five people spread out amongst 15
chairs.
You're eating your balls and I didn't know how to handle it.
And I went up there and I just bombed and said,
oh I was supposed to do five minutes.
I bailed like two minutes in and said on the Mike,
I told you that.
I said to the host Jack,
go jack on Balan in all the comics went ahh.
And then I felt like a fucking pussy and I want to do is just walk off stage
getting my car and drive home.
But I was so humiliated.
I sat in the first fucking chair that was open,
which was like two rows in and just sat there with my head down wanting to leave
the whole time.
And sat there throughout the rest of the fucking open mic,
like a scolded child.
And then I drove home and cried classic German Irish.
Rather than dealing with the emotion,
I kept trying to put it outside of my body and it was just hanging in my car the
whole fuck.
It was horrific.
I can't imagine doing that.
And then doing it in front of your tire fucking class.
It was horrific.
So that was my bad.
All right,
you to youtube,
youtube fucking videos of the week.
Uh,
this one,
uh,
Brad Garrett was on the job,
a bay horse show.
If you just want to see a fucking standup comedian in complete,
not giving a shit mode,
just going off.
You got to watch this.
He's absolutely fucking hilarious.
This guy is a true standup comedian.
Like I already loved him from the Ray Romano Shovel and I watched this clip.
This guy is the shit and I would definitely go see him to stand up.
This is what it takes to be a great comedian.
This guy completely doesn't give a fuck.
And there's a bunch of people evidently watching it cause he,
he jokes that all is Ray Romano money has gone saying he invested in,
into this comedy club.
Like he was on a hit series for fucking 10 years,
like 10 years of syndicated money.
That's how much it takes to open a fucking room in Vegas.
When you're in name,
he's clearly juggled,
but people know is he broke his,
he doing heroin.
Heroin?
No.
What's great is he just at one point he's throwing chips at people who were in
Vegas.
He,
you go,
you'll white trash,
you know,
he doesn't call it it's fucking hill.
You got to see it.
So all of these are going to be on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
Um,
we put this one up last week,
but I forgot the hype it insane robot movie.
You got to see this thing.
It's just a clip from a fucking great movie.
And also the greatest wrestling clip I've ever seen in my life.
Nia.
She wants her five minutes of her life back.
He's just the greatest thing I've ever seen in my life.
The name of the video is the most illegal thing I've seen in wrestling history.
You have to watch it.
It's fucking awesome and quick.
Overrated,
underrated.
Overrated.
The black eyed peas,
uh,
the bill,
the black ips are terrible.
I'm pissed.
I watched that halftime,
uh,
bullshit at the Superbowl,
even on mute with the promise that it was going to be something I didn't want to
miss.
They suck and that noise they call music is the worst crap ever.
Um,
I walk out,
I never watched the halftime shows.
They're fucking horrific.
They were very different before Fergie showed up.
And I'll just leave it at that.
Okay.
And if you know them,
you know that what I'm saying is true.
You're blaming the white girl.
Okay.
Is it racist,
racist,
a car sex,
underrated is often unappreciated.
Lol.
There's nothing like pulling over on the side of a busy interstate and getting
it on what he says or stumbling out of a bar with some random chick you brought
a few drinks for and convinced to leave with you going to a car and not even,
not even making out of the parking lot.
It's just oh and bang and basically it's just plain awesome.
Uh,
I purchased,
let,
let it go and loved it.
Thank you.
Um,
I would say that sex in the car was way better back in the day when they had
bench seats and actually he made huge cars.
But,
uh,
I think it's,
I dunno,
you know,
I don't like the look.
I don't like the fucking look in your Goddamn I.
Okay.
And I'm not getting into her personal life,
but we don't get enough.
We don't have enough memories.
[inaudible] yeah.
Wow.
Yeah.
The older cars are better because they have
more room.
Fucking gotta be kidding me.
You know what?
Why don't you get your trampy ass outta here.
Please meet you think I,
you think I didn't realize that when I met you.
Huh?
I think I didn't realize,
you know
you've had a sex life before you got them.
Right.
So what is the problem is when it took male whore meeting a female horn,
you were a man whore.
I was not.
No,
you are a man.
I was always the ladies.
Yeah.
Wow.
I wasn't looking at me.
I look like fucking howdy duty with a fucking Nah,
but you got that whole little like sexy,
angry thing going on.
Women like this and yet,
you know what I don't like.
I don't like being pandering to them,
do whatever the fuck he said.
Oh,
here's one last quick thing.
I always say I'm gonna fucking ended.
I never do.
All right.
Corporations,
uh,
selling your information.
Hey Bill,
I did listen to your podcast for a while now and think,
ah,
they're very entertaining and funny.
I do have to admit however,
that every time I,
maybe I'd read this last week,
I can't remember,
but I'm just happy because I ended up being right here.
Uh,
I do have to admit,
however,
that every time you talk about the conspiracy theories and people tracking your
electronic purchases and whatnot,
I roll my eyes and wonder why you're so crazy.
However,
this is why I actually started reading better is I pause now and I look at the
next three words and it fucking works out now.
Lot of the king's speech.
Is that what that movie's about?
Hi.
No,
yeah,
I'm not watching it.
It's good.
It's really,
really good.
It looks like it took place in another time.
So that automatic place in another time.
It's a period piece about reading.
It's fucking horrific
cause that's what I was just talking about.
It's whatever.
What did you think about your time in that Fucking Ltd?
Um,
however,
recently.
Ah,
that's one of my favorite cars.
You just ruined it.
You know what?
I'm going to have to tell a fucking story that's going to ruin something for
you.
Let me think.
What are you into?
Going into the mall?
Yes.
We'll tell him.
I got at the fucking whatever orange Julius stand.
No.
However,
recently
browsing the Internet and started noticing ads on every page that directly
related to something I had just purchased online.
How fucked up is that?
Now I knew things like this happened and that site's kept certain information
about you,
but I guess since I never saw any visual evidence of this,
I simply put it in the back of my mind.
I never worried about it.
However,
now I had direct in your face evidence of being tracked.
I have to say I felt a bit violated.
Yeah,
it's weird.
Like somebody just sitting there watching what the fuck you're doing.
Um,
anyways,
he says to think that the ads were specifically being put up for me on every
website I went to struck me as a huge invasion of privacy and it was a bit
unnerving.
Um,
this was a week,
two ago and ever since then I've become a bit paranoid about the amount of
information that is out there about me.
I thought about all the Times I've entered my credit card information
information or home address online in order to make some purchases and went
through every website I could think of.
Jury set information,
dude,
it's over.
It's already up there.
Um,
I know once it's out there,
it's impossible to take back,
but I have to do what I can do.
I've changed my email address,
my old email address,
had my full name in it,
um,
started shredding everything with my address on it and started using cash only
to make purchases so that someone can't track it,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
yeah,
I actually,
somebody sent me an email the other day update some four year old kid,
got a um,
got a,
uh,
what do,
what do you call it?
A credit card
application application.
Yeah.
From American Express.
And why are we talking about how if you use Gmail,
if you're having an email conversation with somebody and you mentioned something
like,
Oh yeah,
I'll meet you after I go to the spa.
And next thing you know there's all these ads for spa stuff.
Like someone's,
yeah,
it,
Google reads your email,
it picks up on key phrases and then just automatically pops up ads around it
that you could correlate to that email that you just,
for some reason you're looking at an email like,
like it's illegal for you to read my mail mail.
Right?
So the old school shit,
right.
But somehow online they can just look at that because it's just,
no,
now this is what morons are gonna say,
Look Dude,
to me,
oh,
it's just a computer program is just picking up certain words
like this.
This is how you gradually work your way to having a microchip and your forehead
is they just incrementally,
yeah,
take away what they used to not be able to do.
And then what happens is people die off and then the new standard is where this
new generation was born.
It's like being taken off the gold standard where cash used to represent gold.
You brought your golden,
silver was heavy,
it was dangerous and it was a pain in the ass to carry around.
Some banks are like,
we'll bring the shit in the US,
we'll give you these pieces of paper cash that represent the gold.
You give his $20 in gold,
we'll give you a $20 bill.
And anytime you want you can come back down and fucking,
you know,
get you $20 in gold.
And after a while we just kept using the piece of paper.
People forgot about the gold.
The fuckers who brought the golden died.
They took us off the gold standard.
Now you can't claim it.
What happened?
All that gold and silver,
those fucking can stick.
They kept it,
they kept a ship.
So that's what I'm saying about all this other stuff is like all this stuff that
you used to not be able to do like this.
People being born now will not remember a time when people couldn't just,
you know,
when the government couldn't listen to and record every phone conversation you
ever fucking had.
And I don't know,
people get like,
I don't know.
This is the type of shit if you talk about it,
people think you're fucking paranoid.
Well it's also like,
you know the stuff that you put on like Facebook,
I don't care.
I'm just picturing you in a Goddamn car with your fucking hot ass feet up
against the fucking window.
All right.
This bill,
his podcasts is too God damn long at this point.
Wow.
Uh,
I already did like another 25 minutes other than this was like an hour and 15
minutes and cut off that part.
If you,
which part?
The part where we're talking about the stuff with the cars was probably be the
fucking best part of the podcast at this point.
Alright.
Sheath and I look,
I got you got,
you know,
that's what I'm here for.
It helps give and take.
Yeah.
Comedy.
Somebody's got to get hurt this week.
It was me right?
As the next time.
Is it going to be me?
No,
I wouldn't do that cause I got to fucking live with you.
Yeah.
I got to live with you.
Well,
that's it.
Listen,
I have to rest up my voice because I'm singing a macho man in my fucking
underwear tomorrow and glee.
And that's it.
Thanks for listening to podcasts this week,
and thanks to each and every one of you out there for making it number 52
on the podcast.
Keep reaching for the stars.
That's right.
I don't give a fuck.
Ah,
that's it.
You guys have a good weekend.
A congratulations to Greenbay my condolences to a Pittsburgh and,
but he'd go fuck yourself,
right?
[inaudible]
oh,
Ooh.
[inaudible].